James wrote in, James says, Hey David, do
you think more Republicans don't stand up
to Trump because they're spineless or because
they're unprincipled?
I actually think there's a third option here
that you're not mentioning, which is an important
one, which is a lot of them do agree with
Trump.
So the 60 million people or whatever that
voted for Trump who also vote for senators
and members of Congress.
Those senators and members of Congress may
have different reasons why they are not standing
up to Trump with what exceptions.
Like Justin Amash I hope is, I know it's not
a mash.
I think I pronounced it a mash and someone
said it's Amash, Justin Amash and you know
Rick Wilson, who I interviewed on the program
or Kellyanne Conway's husband right there.
There's a bunch of different things going
on.
Some Republicans intellect that office aren't
standing up to Trump because they are spineless.
They just are kind of go with the flow and
they don't want to rock the boat and they
don't want to possibly have negative electorial
repercussions for their reelection campaigns
if they stand up to Trump.
Some are unprincipled in the sense that it's
all a power game to them it's sport.
As I said before, it's about wins and losses.
It doesn't matter if Obamacare is the same
thing that was proposed by the Heritage Foundation
in the 90s which is a very sort of corporatist
center, right?
Plan to give tens of millions of new customers
to for-profit insurance companies.
Doesn't matter.
It's something that Obama did.
It's a loss.
And the way to put a box to check off a box
on the wind column is to repeal it and get
rid of it.
Even if you would kick tens of millions of
people off of healthcare.
It's just sport.
And a lot of these Republicans really are
unprincipled and we know that because they
espouse one set of principles and then often
live by a completely different set of principles.
So that's group number two.
There are also Republicans that just agree
with Trump.
I mean at this point we have to sort of realize
that there are some Republicans who were just
kind of coalesced or emboldened to go public
with their beliefs and those beliefs always
matched many of Donald Trump's beliefs.
They just weren't saying it out loud.
Now, a lot of people in the Trump era are
saying the quiet part outline out loud.
There are also republicans that are, I mean
at this point there is such a thing as a Trumpist
republican that is a wing of the Republican
Party and some Republicans aren't standing
up to Trump because they simply agree with
the guy, so spineless and principled or or
agree with him.
The answer is yes.
All three of these, depending who you're talking
about for different people it is different
ones and this is why I've been now saying
for months Trump is going to go eventually.
It could be in a year and a half.
It could be in five and a half years.
But once he does, that doesn't mean that Trump
goes away unless we make it go away unless
we reject it completely and vote out and not
vote in all of the people that are subscribing
to this sort of coarsened, uh, outlandish
ignorance, uh, a glorification, that glorification
of ignorance that has taken place within Trump
and politics.
And this is why it's really important to understand
that Donald Trump was always, uh, some Donald
Trump is a symptom and not the disease, as
I've said before.
And even when you cure the symptom of trumpet
by removing him, the disease that allowed
him to come to power in 2016 will still be
there unless we fully cure it.
And that is why we need to be thinking beyond
just Trump and 2020.
We need to be thinking about the House and
Senate.
We need to be thinking about 20, 22 when Democrats
will have more possibilities to take over
control of the Senate, which I just don't
see any path to doing in 2020.
We've got to be thinking bigger and beyond
Trump.
And I think a lot of people in our audience,
at least from the emails I'm getting,
are thinking bigger in that way, which is
a good thing.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a member or a patron to get instant
access for the bonus show off speaker, the
David Pakman